libs of tick tock doing some
investigative journalism um
one of the only people
in the country doing actual
investigative journalism and and what
she's doing here is uh
you know you would think that if there
were real journalists working for these
supposed news outlets that one of them
would have done this
given that we're there's this
conversation about children's hospitals
and so-called gender affirming surgeries
and procedures
and
which of those procedures do they
inflict on minors
and which do they reserve for adults
well a good way to find out is to just
call them
not as a member of the media but just
call them and ask
that's exactly what
libsytic talk did and uh let's start
going through this audio here this is
what by the way this is the i don't know
if i mentioned this is the um
children's hospital
what is this children's national
hospital in dc okay
thank you for college national hospital
your call may be recorded for quality
assurance i was calling uh for
information about gender affirming
hysterectomies
okay it's a gender forming history
i've been in touch with quite a few
hospitals um and a lot of them well they
said they won't do it for for my 16 year
old um and then i was told that this
hospital might and i also saw it on your
website um so if you guys do
uh do it for 16 year olds i'll i would
be happy for you know to come for a
consultation or whatever it takes let me
get you over to
the operator and i hate to transfer you
i just i just need to want to know if if
you guys do
service that age you know before
obviously
before coming you know coming all the
way for
an in-person consult and going through
all the paperwork yeah it depends each
department is different some some
departments cut off for 18 hours how old
is your patient 16.
okay all right so they're in the clear
i'll email the um got the call and see
what we can in the meantime if you still
want me to transfer you i still
translate the survey all right so pause
it there for a sec
so we've already heard from the operator
oh well she said it very clear you're in
the clear at the age of 16 you're in the
clear
now this is very different if you were
to call
uh and this is the investigation that
media outlets have done
where as members of the media they call
the hospital's pr department
and say hey
you're being criticized for doing this
awful thing do you actually do that
thing and then the hospital say no no we
don't do that
and then the media says well you see
there it is
they would never lie to us
end of
discussion but if you call them
as a potential
patient
customer willing to give your money you
get a very different answer uh
conversation continues let's play a
little bit more of this
hi i was calling um because i'm looking
for information about the gender
affirming hysterectomies that you guys
offer
okay
yes
um this is the clinic
did you want to make an appointment
so i was just wondering i've i've
contacted quite a few hospitals already
um it seems like it's
difficult to find one that does the
operation um for my 16 year old and i
was told that you guys
do do that um so
if you do it for 16 year olds then yes
i'd love to schedule um an appointment a
consultation whatever you need
if you don't mind me asking um
what is your child gender change into so
i can point you to the right direction
pause it there a second
what did your child's gender change into
this is someone at the hospital at in
the relevant department asking that
question
what did your child's gender change into
what
what does that
mean
and and by the way so it's like because
they're right there's not just two
options
so hysterectomy means that we're dealing
with a girl we can assume
so maybe the hospital worker knows that
much
but she's not a girl anymore but maybe
not a boy she could be something else
uh
it's also like why why does that matter
to you
i mean is there
difference does that make
anyway let's let's continue
yeah well he transitioned to a male you
know he already had the top surgery um
and now we're looking for the
hysterectomy
okay beautiful so i'm gonna transfer you
to the gyn nurse line one of the nurses
will give you a call to
give you more information and to let you
know the steps
and the protocol that they do for that
okay
okay so so they do so they would do it
um for uh for that age
yes
all right there you go that's it
good so confirmed with two people the
hospital operator and then someone in
the relevant department
yes they do
gender affirming quote unquote
hysterectomies for 16 year olds right
there from the horse's mouth so to speak
now uh this was published and shortly
after that
children's national hospital put out a
statement
and here's their statement
we are aware of the audio recording
circulating on twitter here are the
facts
we foster a welcoming and inclusive
environment for all serving our lgbtq
plus patients and families in the full
spectrum of their care
we do not provide gender affirming
surgery for anyone under the age of 18.
we do not provide hormone therapy to
children before puberty begins
care is individualized for each patient
always involves families making
decisions in coordination with a team of
highly trained pediatric specialists
now once again the media is taking that
and saying well see debunked
we have on tape
the people at the hospital saying yes we
do that for 16 year olds
so either
the hospital is lying now in an effort
to cover their ass which by the way
that's the correct answer here or the
people at the hospital were lying
someone's lying
the hospital is lying one way or another
the person who wrote this statement was
lying or the people at the hospital that
uh that you heard in the clip there they
were lying
i mean
does the hospital have a policy against
doing gender affirming hysterectomies
for 16 year olds and yet they were going
to do it
anyway well that's a scandal too i mean
no matter what you the hospital doesn't
come out clean here
and yet the kind of hopeless feeling
that you you get as always is that
even though it's right there plain as
day it just doesn't matter there's no
no further investigation from any
relevant authority this is in dc okay
uh you think the mayor of dc is not
going to put any pressure on this the
police aren't going to show up
and really the entire statement is
mind-boggling
what about this part here we do not
provide hormone therapy to children
before puberty begins
okay
what what's the significance of that
you don't provide hormone therapy to
children before puberty begins
but you do provide it after puberty
begins or when puberty is beginning
they're still children though
aren't they
this is something that i've heard from
trans activists actually
not the first time this is something
i've heard frequently over the last few
weeks especially um as they've been
denying that this that these things are
done to children at all
and i i've heard this well this isn't
done to children this it doesn't happen
until puberty
what do you mean but so we're talking
about 11 and 12 year olds or even
younger they're not they don't you don't
see them as kids
well the answer is they don't
and now you start to get the full
picture maybe you start to understand
what's really going on here
and this is how this all gets wrapped in
with the normalization of pedophilia the
reason why that is happening
kids at drag shows and all the rest of
it the sexualization of children the
normalization of pedophilia this is all
happening at the same time as the gender
affirming surge or so-called gender
firming search all this is happening
it's all it's all part of the same
program
because you can hear them saying it
right there it's like well well actually
you know 12 year olds aren't even
children
as you can see they're setting the stage
here
and then let's also keep in mind and i
think it's important to expose the fact
that they're lying about the
hysterectomies and i'm glad that we have
this investigation that confirms that
but let's also not allow them to make
the whole conversation about the
hysterectomies because it is probably
true
that most hospitals and clinics in
america at least officially don't
perform these that particular procedure
on minors
that's probably the case
um at least not officially
but
that is only a small
portion of the overall picture here
they all do top surgery they all do
double mastectomies on kids all of them
do
that that's not any better
so what they're saying is we will
mutilate certain parts of the child's
body but not but then other parts we
wait until you know they're right when
they turn 18.
that is not
better at all that that is that is not a
good excuse
not even close to a good excuse
so let's not let they they want the
whole conversation to be focused around
the hysterectomies because
they feel like they're on the safest
ground there
although the whole concept of gender
from a hysterectomy is horrifying uh
they know that like generally that is
that they do wait till 18 for that
they don't want to talk about the top
surgeries
because they're doing that to 13 year
olds
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're joined we're forming a cult
then all you gotta do is click the
subscribe button and ring the bell below
uh this video to stay up to date with
all my content and if you want even more
you can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast looking forward to welcoming you
to the sweet baby gang